quello che vi racconterò questa sera è
un racconto su una sfida una sfida che
non è ancora terminata ma che è in corso
ed è quella che stiamo percorrendo persi
laboratori degli istituti clinici e
scientifici maugeri per cercare di
trovare una soluzione ai nostri alle
malattie dei nostri pazienti come sapete
se avete sentito ci occupiamo di aritmie
su base genetica ma ritmi e non quelle
che danno un po fastidio al cuore a
ritmi e quelle gravi che provocano
proprio l'arresto cardiaco di cui si
parlava nel filmato per cui soltanto
quando l'arresto cardiaco avviene
soltanto una scarica elettrica che può
terminare e quindi salvare la persona
quindi in pazienti che hanno nel dna dei
difetti genetici che predispongono a
questo tipo di aritmie e molto
importante avere la miglior cura
possibile
sapete quando si lavora con dei malati
che hanno delle malattie genetiche il
problema è che sono dei pazienti molto
diversi dagli altri
nascono malati e saranno malati tutta la
vita e non sanno che una cura oggi non
esiste e tela chiedono costantemente
ogni volta è il secondo problema è che
non solo sanno di essere malati ma sanno
che trasmetteranno questa malattia e
quindi tutta l'ansia e la sofferenza che
loro hanno ai loro figli quindi
lavorando con loro
ti viene la voglia di cercare di
risolvere il problema è di andare oltre
e questo concetto che espresso nel
titolo se non possiamo curare la
malattia perché i farmaci non sono
abbastanza perché anche i defibrillatori
impiantabili non sono abbastanza
possiamo cercare di aggiustare dna e
siamo una generazione fortunata perché
noi e forse speriamo di riuscire a
portare la nostra fortuna diventare la
fortuna dei pazienti perché in realtà
questi sono gli anni in cui è nata e si
sta sviluppando la terapia genica
cos'è però effettivamente la terapia
genica di cui si sente parlare ma non è
ancora un qualcosa che
gli ospedali che è presente che è
realmente un alternativa oggi per la
stragrande maggioranza dei pazienti
il sogno della terapia genica dei medici
dei pazienti che è lo stesso sogno che
condividiamo noi cercando di fare loro
sperando di aiutarci a fare magari
fornendoci informazioni sulla loro
malattia ai dati sul loro sulla loro
situazione quella di riparare i geni
malati
il secondo sogno perché in alcuni
tessuti riparare gene malato è più
difficile o forse non è neanche
possibile è quello di riparare le
conseguenze del gene dello specifico
gene malato è una terapia che ha
qualcosa di diverso siamo abituati a
pensare che la terapia sia una molecola
chimica che poi viene messa in una
compressa in una fiala in una modalità
di somministrazione in questo caso
dobbiamo somministrare degli acidi
nucleici gli acidi nucleici sono il dna
e la sua alleato che rna e cioè quella
diciamo componente del processo che
nasce nel dna che alle informazioni per
cui per produrre tutte le proteine
dell'organismo a diventare nel processo
successivo nel rene ha effettivamente
quell'acido nucleico che permetterà di
produrre la proteina quindi dalla teoria
alla pratica e mettere un acido nucleico
che noi vediamo qui rappresentato dentro
a una terapia è un qualcosa di difficile
perché non possiamo pensare di
somministrarlo così come nudo dobbiamo
pensare di organizzarlo in un qualche
modo ma poi non è neanche così semplice
perché in realtà ogni malattia a una
serie di meccanismi che si attivano
quando c'è un difetto genetico che alla
fine alterano la proteina e spesso
questi difetti sono diversi da paziente
a paziente anche con la stessa malattia
quindi il passo fondamentale quello di
concepire
una strategia per cui noi usando o dna e
rna riusciamo a contrastare lo sviluppo
della malattia e quindi la
manifestazione dei suoi sintomi
ora questo tipo di processo ovviamente
implica che noi conosciamo molto bene le
basi della malattia che cosa succede
quando la proteina invece di essere
normale alterate alterati in quello
specifico modo questo ovviamente può
essere possibile solo quando noi abbiamo
un modello animale di malattia che ci
permette di capire questi meccanismi
quindi c'è un percorso lungo per
arrivare a concepire queste famose
pillole di dna che noi vorremmo dare ai
nostri pazienti
in realtà quando si pensa di costruire
una terapia genica per i pazienti
bisogna inizialmente pensare se il
difetto della nostra proteina è un
difetto che porta ad avere una funzione
ridotta quindi noi abbiamo una proteina
che dovrebbe fare una qualsiasi cosa
trasportare degli ioni sintetizzare
aiutare la sintesi di qualche altra
sostanza fosfori lare quindi attivare
delle altre proteine qualunque funzione
la mutazione la riduce oppure molto più
raramente ci sono delle dei casi in cui
la mutazione in realtà fa iperfunzionare
la proteina che diventa capace di fare
quello che dovrebbe fare normalmente ma
moltiplicato magari per 10 volte
purtroppo questo non è un effetto
positivo anche se sembra la super
proteina la proteina deve fare
esattamente la quantità e deve essere
presente nella quantità giusta per
svolgere il proprio ruolo
quindi come vedremo tra poco se noi
scegliamo dna e rna dipende anche dal
tipo di difetto genetico che è presente
alla fine l'altra scelta fondamentale è
quella di come facciamo a fare arrivare
questo dna nella cellula del paziente
perché in questo caso non parliamo più
questo è un grande cambio di paradigma
non arriviamo più a dover curare
l'organo in generale quindi mettere
sangue delle molecole che poi si
attaccano sulla superficie delle cellule
inducono qualche effetto curativo ma
dobbiamo esattamente entrare nel maggior
numero possibile di cellule dell'organo
e portarci l'acido nucleco quindi dna un
rene a che serve quindi come possiamo
fare una somministrazione che porti
capillarmente a livello della singola
cellula e anzi all'interno del nucleo
della singola cellula quello che noi
vogliamo a somministrare in realtà fra
tanti lettori che ci sono quelli che si
stanno utilizzando di più nel mondo e
che sembrano essere per ora non
sorpassati nella loro capacità di fare
quello che appunto va fatto di arrivare
al nucleo delle singole cellule lo fanno
degli storici nemici della salute
dell'uomo e cioè i virus ma dei virus
che non possono essere i virus che fanno
quello che normalmente il virus va cioè
entrare nella cellule mettere nel nucleo
il loro dna per costruire altri virus e
uccidere la cellula dell'organismo
ospite
ovviamente sono dei virus modificati che
la medicina la scienza la biologia
molecolare riuscita a produrre proprio
per la terapia ben genica con delle
caratteristiche molto particolari prima
di tutto abbiamo dei virus che sanno
andare all organo specifico quindi ne
abbiamo che vanno al muscolo che vanno
al cuore che vanno al cervello e questo
già ci permette di non andare a fare
terapia genica di farli in parte minima
dove non deve essere fatto
secondo anno svengo sono stati privati
della capacità di replicarsi noi
ricercatori cosa dobbiamo fare a questo
punto scegliere il tipo di virus che ci
serve è inserire all'interno del virus
la strategia che abbiamo immaginato a
base di dna base di rna base di tutti e
due ma comunque la strategia che viene
dall atto di conoscenza della malattia
ed ipotesi di come correggerla il virus
diventa quindi la siringa superspeciale
molecolare che in grado di portare la
nostra terapia all
all'interno del nucleo della cellula
come vedete in quel poligono azzurro è
il virus con dentro il costrutto che noi
prepariamo quindi il acido nucleico che
dovrebbe servire nel caso specifico a
quel punto il virus entra questo dna e
rna che noi abbiamo prodotto entra
all'interno del nucleo e comincia a far
produrre la proteina o la sostanza che
noi abbiamo bisogno di far produrre la
cosa incredibile è che questa attività
finora è stata documentata che può
proseguire per dieci anni ma
probabilmente anche di più quindi una
terapia che con un'iniezione può
permettere a una persona di ricevere un
beneficio almeno per dieci anni i
pazienti di cui noi ci occupiamo sono
pazienti che appunto hanno arresti
cardiaci sono spesso giovani e molto
giovani a volte anche bambini e tendono
ad avere questi eventi aritmici durante
l'attività sportiva durante l'emozione
durante i periodi di stress sono persone
che alla fine sono terrorizzate di
vivere perché qualunque emozione nella
loro vita positiva negativa o anche il
gioco la corsa diventa potenzialmente il
fattore che li porta ad arresto cardiaco
spesso sono quelle quei calciatori quei
giocatori di altissimo livello in cui
non è mai stata posta una di queste
diagnosi che purtroppo muoiono
improvvisamente sul campo per questi
pazienti
la malattia si chiama una delle malattie
che si associa proprio alle alterazioni
durante l'attività fisica con l'emozione
è chiamata tachicardia catecolamine rhji
ca e è data appunto da una mutazione nel
dna che porta a una sintesi di una
proteina che non funziona oppure in
un'altra forma della malattia in una
proteina che funziona troppo in questo
modo vediamo i due approcci terapeutici
sia una proteina che non funziona
la strategia che possiamo utilizzare che
noi abbiamo utilizzato è quella
di far produrre dal virus esattamente la
proteina che è mancante quella che
danneggiata viene eliminata dall
organismo quindi la nostra strategia
diventerà quella di puntare sul dna di
inserire questo dna della proteina
alterata all'interno del vettore virale
e poi una volta costruito questo vettore
portarlo in vivo e iniettarlo in un
topolino che si affetto dalla malattia
con questo approccio nei topolini che
abbiamo studiato affetti dalla
tachicardia catecolamine rhji ca
abbiamo visto che un elettrocardiogramma
come questo che anche a chi non conosce
l'elettrocardiogramma da un senso di
irregolarità e dibattiti fatti in modo
strano trasformarlo in un battito molto
regolare questo cosa vuol dire vuol dire
che questi topolini dopo essere stati
trattati con la terapia sono diventati
in grado di avere uno stress importante
a cui prima corrispondeva all insorgenza
di questa aritmia che poi degenera in
arresto cardiaco
invece senza avere questo tipo di
episodio di malattia e per la vita che
ha un topolino in un laboratorio
riuscire ad avere sempre questa attività
che con una singola iniezione persiste
per più di un anno e mezzo è sicuramente
un risultato in linea con l'aspettativa
nell'uomo di avere una possibilità
ancora più lunga paragonata alla vita
dell'uomo e quindi avere una decina
d'anni di trattamento quando invece
abbiamo una proteina che funziona troppo
ovviamente non possiamo dire adesso noi
mettiamo nel virus dna della proteina la
facciamo produrre perché già funziona
troppo
l'approccio non funzionerebbe allora in
questo caso per correggere l'effetto
della mutazione sulla proteina dobbiamo
puntare sull'altro acido nucleico e cioè
puntare sulle rna rna e quello che poi
presa l'informazione copiata
l'informazione dal dna rende possibile
il produrre la proteina ma se noi
riusciamo a sintetizzare
un rna che identifica esattamente qual è
la proteina che non funziona e ne
inibisce la trascrizione quindi fa sì
che le rna non venga eliminato le renne
a che poi porterebbe alla produzione
allora abbiamo una specie di rna che
offusca rna dannoso e quindi permette
specificatamente di produrre solo
proteina sana ma non proteina malata
questa strategia si basa su una tecnica
che si chiama interferenza del rna
proprio perché combatte le renne ha
ancora una volta abbiamo iniettato nel
nostro topolino questi vettori e siamo
riusciti ad abolire completamente le
aritmie
ora che cosa vuol dire avere fatto uno
studio di questo tipo in un modello pre
clinico per quel mondo della terapia
genica una prova su un animale
transgenico quindi che abbia la malattia
come l'uomo è una prova considerata il
passo che può portare già alla clinica
quindi siamo abbastanza avanti ed
effettivamente in questo momento queste
due terapie sono in sviluppo presso una
company americana che sta cercando di
valutare se avrà riusciranno a fare un
disegno sperimentale per il trial
clinico
la cosa più importante di tutta questa
vicenda è il coinvolgimento dei nostri
pazienti la speranza per i nostri
pazienti che questo possa essere la fine
di un incubo lungo una vita e una
speranza per le generazioni future
grazie
[Applauso]